that's what you guys deal with all the
time all the time you're not number
you're a single man I'm a single man you
think you know veg I'm not a
gynecologist I feel like I know more
than I probably did I know all I need to
know about vaginas man I know about as
much as him and that means nothing I
know that that's where I came out of and
that's pretty much it I actually was the
c-section so I didn't
[Music]
you know what I know about periods zilch
I imagine that cramps happen all around
everywhere because every month the egg
comes down the fallopian tubes from the
ovaries into the uterus and then that's
that's got to come out every month
because when my girls talk to me they
like it feels like an ice flake like
scraping out the bottom of the pot
that's when there's too much yeast in
your vagina it's like when a vagina like
inflates I imagine things something
grows because of yeast what it really
says about the vagina is you've got a
complicated beautiful ecosphere
happening there like a cottage cheese
kind of a thing huh like a fromage
it sounds like when you get hit by a
nuke it's an energy drink
my understanding is an urban myth um
toxic shock syndrome is definitely real
it's real it is definitely real I heard
it was a myth is it like if they put
something in the pudenda I don't know so
what happens when you leave a tampon in
too long they put like a double maybe it
toxic by the woman I put my spare change
in there
it's like stuff that comes out of the
vagina that you don't mean for it to
come out
you know like involuntarily stuff that
comes out of it like going up exactly it
probably produces discharge to get rid
of all of the other crazy stuff
happening to it it's kind of like when
you pull out the dipstick on your car I
think it's like the body like maybe
protecting itself right like I'll get a
little discharge on my nipple ring
sometimes
[Music]
HPV is is a virus like when when it gets
like HPV stands for human have blown
McHappy loma virus and I know nothing
beyond that he probably stands for a
virus that causes cervical cancer got
the bumpy's going on people talk about
all the time I know there's like
commercials right and men are men are
carriers but I don't think there's a
test for men who have it I learned that
from girls and I'm just gonna assume
that it's true
I feel like HPV is something I should
know Oh
hell no not me no way the fact that you
have to say maintain that's like we
couldn't do that but you don't really
have to maintain a penis right oh my
gosh do you penises are easy dicks are
so something this is a big hole compares
our hole you know how hard it is for
them to keep this shut constantly to
like prevent germs from getting in a lot
of work but you guys love that you guys
are like yeah that's the area but
straight guys love vaginas like they
love expensive cars like they love the
idea of them but they have no real clue
how they operate oh good to know
honestly if I had a vagina I would not
know what to do with these flaps what I
look at this vagina and I think why
don't we just not have wars why don't we
just not have Wars why don't we just
start getting along
[Music]